[Music]  Dakota Johnson is addressing  relationship rumors about she and  co-star Jamie Dornan onset of the erotic  Fifty Shades franchise that's dinner  with me okay fine I will have dinner  with you because I'm hungry in the  February issue of Vogue Dakota jokes we  hate each other and we're having an  affair  so everybody's right he was funny and we  like got along on a comedic level and  that was really important and different  than anyone that had come in before the  sequel drops just in time for  Valentine's Day on February 10th and  features a single from Zayn Malik and  Taylor Swift titled forever this time no  rules  Thursday Swift posted this apparent  screenshot from the upcoming music video  to ring in Shane's birthday  [Music]  you